so I am currently practicing
non-monogamy living with a girlfriend
that I'm sexually active with and have
other lovers and sweethearts in addition
to her I'm free to date anybody right
now I'm I'm just dating yeah last few
months yeah I've been single just uh
that's I said once in the last few
months so yeah
recently you separated from them like a
really long-term partner so have more
openness in my life so I've mostly been
with women in the last few months I've
been desiring to like physically be with
a man like sexually in a way that
basically giving over control okay I
want like a guy to [ __ ] my brains out
and like should overpower me and like
almost like the [ __ ] that I've been told
my whole life is is the way men and
women are supposed to relate like that
masculinity is powerful and femininities
to be so submissive and like I've kind
of rejected that my life are like
haven't desired that because it's been
like in mainstream but like now I'm like
really interested in in playing into
that role a bit more and like seeing
what it feels like to give over power to
someone and be totally in their hands a
big part of my sexual life and sexual
fantasy has been sort of informed by an
attraction to the fantasy and unwilling
partner vicious fantasies I love men and
so the idea of two beautiful beings
being with me and treating me like a
queen like feeding me grapes kind of
thing and like fanning me like one man
could do that but it'd be so much better
if there were two I just really wanna
kind of like a really nice girl and like
someone who likes to get like maybe a
little rough like a little slapping oh
yeah I like slapping and I like being
like really sweet but I really rough at
the same time kind of like going switch
it back and forth just like Bostic
arounds I remember when I the summer I
was with that girl I wanted to tie her
up and
like it's like leave her there like to
put her up to a pole and it's like leave
her there in like a theater or some like
that it was crazy stuff now like a
little slave type scenario right like
she would be a down for it obviously
would be crossing boundaries I always
imagined it in a kind of a painstaking
slow process where I'm never quite sure
what's going to happen so for example I
suppose if I was in a public situation
maybe sitting somewhere maybe on a bus I
don't really have too much option of
moving around and I feel someone get a
little bit closer to me and like okay
you know it's crowded sure and then I
feel something else like a hand
wandering I'm like okay well you know
that's like okay like does he know that
that's my but like does he you know you
don't really know and that's kind of
moving around I'm not entirely sure if
he knows what's going on or she I guess
I really want to give over control and
be dominated by man but I also like have
a skepticism I don't know if if a man
wants to dominate me if he wants to do
it for a like respectful reason like if
like does he want to do it because it's
something we agree on and he respects me
and wants to please me or is there
something else going on for him
eventually you start asking questions
about yourself I don't know why I find
something so distasteful so genuinely
distasteful in reality so appealing in
fantasy I can only presume again it's
about power
women are so easily capable of being
with other women but for men it's still
a difficult thing so I'm really
intrigued with the idea of men coming
together and having sexual experiences
without feeling like they're not
sticking to their own identities rather
they're really stepping into their own
skin by experiencing another sexual
encounter I'm very shy guide like Louis
of Siemens on younger now recently I
have more like you know confidence and
so once I do yeah it was a girl I do a
lot of things like I can do a lot of
crazy nuts stuff but I just don't get to
that moment a lot so I guess it's like
kind of like alright girl I can find I
guess in a way I don't know yeah I think
true
I mean Trust is necessary and and
anything I think of any relation that
you would have with another person hmm
the tough part is that so much of this
fantasy is about me not knowing what's
going to happen so the more I plan the
more I know and it's a really tricky
situation I'm trying to figure out how I
can create something that is both safe
and unknown to me it seems a little bit
far-fetched
you